thank you eldesquit the next question is
from tricia she says who will be part of
the 144 thousand i heard an elder at church
say he believes these are all sdas it is true
but i'd like to see what bible verse says that
the 144 000 will be all those who obey god fully
that's as far as i can those who are obedient to
god because the bible says here is the patience of
the sins here they they keep the commandments of
god and the faith of jesus now the character
of god is most clearly expressed in his law
other than the life of christ the 144 000
will have that character in the foreheads
on this earth before he comes by the way all all
those who finally go to heaven will have it so i
cannot say 142 000 only will be averages it will
be those who have committed themselves to obey god
rather the beast are you following me because
there'll be two competing powers as they are now
thus saith the lord and thus save the beast and
the world and the words of the beast are all the
same thing because you don't have three groups the
wheat the tares and the something else is wheat
until sheep and gold so you have the obedient
people of god and everyone else and everyone
else includes the beast the false prophet the
world whomever those who are in 144 000 will be
those who have chosen to obey god fully even
if it means the loss of life they don't care
kill me i'm obeying god i will not obey a
man-made system whose words contradict god
and so obedience to god becomes a a distinguishing
mark of the 144 thousand and that's what i'd say
those who made up their mind to obey god even
unto death as we read in revelation 2 verse 10
be thou thief unto death and i will give you
crown of life that's the 144 000. amen amen
you